ich weiß nicht ob sie es wussten aber
mir war es bisher noch nicht bekannt
dass coldmirror ein eigenes spiel
programmieren möchte und sogar schon
damit angefangen hat darum geht es im
talk mit ihr der auf der gamescom statt
gefunden hat wo klickst du mir eine ecke
mit dem wdr zusammen hatte
und es geht natürlich um noch viel mehr
dieses jahr muss ja nach wird das klar
häuft macht die gamescom happy ja
natürlich
nein ich hab gut gefrühstückt deswegen
das schon viel wert für mich
letztes jahr habe ich mich mehr gefreut
warum dieses jahr sind nicht so wirklich
spiele dabei wo ich mich für
interessierte letzte immer noch skyrim
zwar aus dem und diesmal also 323
simcity bei inter bricht aus oder alte
deponie oder harveys neue augen da
kriegt man was geboten da denkt man
nicht zu alt für liebe rein gesteckt und
so aber das ist doch nur 2d
aber es ist eine story die
dahintersteckt und ein gefühl was
drinsteckt und das hast du bei den
meisten ea games soll ich bin immer
gegen komischerweise aber die haben in
letzter zeit einfach nur scheiße
rausgebracht
ja ich hab mal versuchten point click
adventure selber zu machen ich hab's
doch selber programmiert ein level und
an gerne lust mehr auf lehmann jetzt
denke ich ja ich jetzt lust das zu malen
wir die story zu überleben überlegen und
dann das programmieren und so anderen
leuten zu überlassen die das können so
ein spiel entwickeln kostet ja glaub ich
auch mit bis zu 10 millionen mehr bei
den großen
dann sollen sie mir das alles geben und
dann springe ich mich auch an beim malen
was ist für dich so dass das was im
vordergrund steht beim gaming was was
sagt was das wichtigste ist ich glaube
es ist ähnlich wie beim film dass man
eine andere welt eintauchen kann aber
auch mit der interagieren kann
und im film kannst du nicht eingreifen
und in der gaming welt jetzt zum
beispiel skype mochte ich sehr gerne
oder fallout darf soll dieses setting
und du bist der charakter beginnen und
die museen es wird euren überlebt also
ich mag gerne diese survival games und
sowas suter muss nicht unbedingt sein
aber wenn du geile story hinter steckt
also mich interessiert die story bei
games immer ich arbeite seit zwei jahren
bei you fm und krieg endlich kohle dafür
so nah dass ich games spiele dass man
überhaupt das beste und ich krieg die
spiele umsonst also eigentlich ist es
ideal für mich und dafür habe ich auch
schon spiele gezockt aber halt nicht so
regelmäßig und jetzt sind alle zwei
wochen ein neues spiel
und na klar leidet so ein bisschen der
kanal darunter oder andere videos zu
machen aber dafür extra den kunden games
kanal gemacht wird dass dann auch
nochmal hochladen
also es ist so auf die verschiedenen
fraktionen kommt immer mal wieder was
neues was ist für dich cool down
entweder irgendwelche spiele zocken oder
einfach nur vom pc sitzen und bilder im
internet näher klicken und mich nicht
bewegen dabei das ist cool wenn du auf
bilder klickst was für bilder klicken
dann alles mögliche pornos
also ich lade oder anmache videos wenn
ich lust dazu habe aber wenn ich denke
so jetzt hab ich lange nichts mehr
hochgeladen so und einem monat mal kann
ich jetzt wieder muss man aber etwas
machen aber ich habe jetzt nicht so
dieses gott ich muss jetzt irgendwie den
leuten wieder ich muss meine klickzahlen
hochtreiben keine ahnung also so läuft
das bei mir nicht
aber ja die routine ist jetzt bei mir
schon drin dass ich für den sender
zumindest meine deadlines immer schaffen
das schaffen
das heißt du bist mein gewissen freie
meter bis garnicht redakteuren
angestellte beruflich bin ich ja ist
freiberuflich und das willst du noch wie
lange machen bis ich sterbe bis ich zu
alt bin und nicht mehr ins jugendradio
passe wenn du da keine lust mehr zu als
was würdest du dann das wäre ein traum
ein buch schreiben vielleicht oder auch
games entwickeln keine ahnung also ich
bei mir ist es immer in den schoß
gefallen ankam irgendjemand meinte hey
hast du lust auf das projekt und ich so
ok dann habe ich das gemacht und zack
habe ich seit zwei jahren job nicht
irgendwo so in die der anschluss licht
kommt dass nichts den schoß fällt er
dann bin ich arbeitslos aber auch raich
dann lasse ich mich dann werde ich
youtube partner und dann wenn ich noch
reiche ja wobei reich wird man arbeite
bei rtl.de der prostituierten mich da
auch schon auto von dem was wenn ihr sie
seht einfach mit eiern bewerfen oder so
dann wissen sie wo es langgeht dürfen
hier nicht rein hab lust alles
auszuprobieren aber ich bin immer so ich
bin eher nichts
experte oder meister aber ich will
trotzdem irgendwie zumindest mal so
meine finger rein stecken sondern
ausprobieren ob ich das kann ok und gibt
es nichts wo sozusagen wird es das würde
ich nicht tun
ich kann zum beispiel nicht gut
moderieren oder leute aus fragen so was
was du machst das ist kann er dein
milieu bin lieber zu hause und denke mir
was aus und ich parodie sehr gerne
sachen ja aber so dinge vorstellen die
es noch nicht gibt oder hier irgendwie
auf dem roten teppich leute interviewen
das wurde mir mal angeboten ja habe ich
auch gesagt habe ich gar keinen bock
drauf so egal ob ich george clooney
treffe oder was auch immer so gar nicht
mein ding
hobbymäßig mache ich das jetzt schon
immer nebenbei ich weiß nicht ob ich das
beruflich machen könnte aber ein game
auch wenn es nur point click adventure
ist möchte ich mal machen was wird das
für eine geschichte sein
irgendwas mit außerirdischen der talk
mit papi dem entwickler von edna bricht
aus jan müller michaelis der schließlich
quasi nahtlos an den hiermit kormoran er
ist ja so ein bisschen ihr vorbild was
die click and point adventure
entwicklung angeht und sein thema warum
oder man crytek mal böse darüber spricht
er und wenn es noch ein wenig verrückter
haben wollt dann vielleicht dem mit den
257 us dem schließen erzählt warum er
nackt aggressiver rappt ja das 1 2 oder
3 hammer nicht
ansonsten bis dann bleibt